Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
THE GIRLS WERE OVERWHELMED
WHEN THEY WERE FLOWN TO PARIS.
Adrianne: THIS IS
SO BEAUTIFUL.
Tyra: SHANNON'S FANTASY
BECAME A REALITY...
Shannon: OH, MY WORD!
Tyra: WHEN SHE MET
THE MAN OF HER DREAMS.
THE RIFT WIDENED BETWEEN ROBIN
AND SOME OF THE GIRLS.
Adrianne: HOW DO YOU SAY,
"ADRIANNE HAS
ENORMOUS CHA-CHAS"?
Robin: I DON'T SPEAK
LIKE THAT.
I DON'T ACT LIKE THAT.
I DON'T WANNA HEAR THAT.
Tyra: AND EVERYONE WAS SAD
WHEN KESSE WAS ASKED TO LEAVE.
Robin: KESSE AND MYSELF,
YOU KNOW, USED TO READ--
USED TO READ THE BIBLE TOGETHER.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: OH.
Elyse: COME ON, ADRIANNE.
Man: (speaking indistinctly)
Robin: WHEN MISS KESSE LEFT,
IT WAS HURTFUL TO SEE HER GO.
I PHYSICALLY COULDN'T STAND UP.
I REMEMBER LEANING ON THE WALLS
AND I REMEMBER
GOING TO SIT DOWN.
SHE REMINDED ME OF MY SISTER.
WE WERE SORORITY SISTERS.
WE WERE BOTH FROM THE SOUTH,
ROOMMATES, CHRISTIANS.
SHE WAS MY BEST FRIEND
IN THIS SITUATION.
Shannon: I FELT LIKE
A LITTLE PIECE OF ME WENT AWAY
BECAUSE KESSE WAS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE GIRLS THAT
I'VE HUNG OUT WITH THE MOST
BESIDES ROBIN.
Adrianne: I BELIEVE
IN A HIGHER POWER.
I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT HIGHER POWER
ASKS YOU TO SACRIFICE
YOUR EVERY DAMN MOMENT.
I DO BELIEVE IN GOD.
I'M JUST NOT PSYCHOTIC ABOUT IT.
I HATE HOW ROBIN ROLLS HER EYES
AT ME WHEN I'M, LIKE, PRAYING.
I'LL BE SITTING THERE PRAYING
FOR MY GRANDMA OR SOMETHING,
AND SHE'LL LOOK OVER AT ME
AND ROLL HER EYES.
Elyse: THINGS WOULD HAVE
DEFINITELY SUCKED
IF MY CLOSEST ALLY IN THE HOUSE
HAD BEEN ELIMINATED,
AND I'M REALLY, REALLY GLAD
THAT ADRIANNE STAYED ON.
Adrianne: BOO-YAH.
♪♪♪
Tyra: I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
MORE EDGY, SHANNON.
Shannon: THANKS.
Tyra: I'VE BEEN PHOTOGRAPHED
BY EVERY TOP PHOTOGRAPHER
IN THE WORLD,
AND I'VE TAKEN POINTERS
FROM EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM.
THAT'S WHY I DECIDED TO SHOOT
THE GIRLS MYSELF--
TO SEE WHAT THE GIRLS LOOK LIKE
THROUGH MY LENS AND HOW THEY
CONNECT WITH THE PHOTOGRAPHER.
THAT IS SO GORGEOUS, ELYSE.
Elyse: NOW THAT FEWER
AND FEWER GIRLS ARE LEFT,
I'M STARTING TO TAKE
THE COMPETITION
MUCH MORE SERIOUSLY.
I LOVE THAT.
THERE YOU GO.
Shannon: IT IS
A LOT OF PRESSURE
BECAUSE, UM, THE FOUR OF US
THAT ARE LEFT IN THE HOUSE
ARE, LIKE, STARING OUR DREAM
RIGHT IN THE FACE.
Tyra: STAY THERE.
WHEN I WAS PHOTOGRAPHING
THE GIRLS, I FELT LIKE
THEY WERE FINALLY REALIZING
THE POSSIBILITY OF BECOMING
A MAJOR STAR.
OKAY.
Adrianne: THEY'RE REALLY
NARROWING IT DOWN TO WHO HAS
WHAT IT TAKES TO BE A TOP MODEL
AND WHO DOESN'T.
♪♪♪
Tyra: IT'S ALL ABOUT PROFILE
AND LOOKING TO THE SKY
AND FEELING LIKE AN ANGEL.
Robin: WHAT COMES WITH THIS
IS POWER.
THE RIGHT PERSON CAN USE THIS
AS A MODEM TO TOUCH PEOPLE,
TO MAKE CHANGE.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT,
WE GOT YOU, ROBIN.
Robin: YES, MA'AM.
♪♪♪
Tyra: WE TOOK THE GIRLS
TO THE HOUSE OF CARVEN, WHICH IS
THE OLDEST COUTURE HOUSE
IN ALL OF PARIS.
Shannon: NOW THIS IS
MY FAVORITE THING.
NO LIE.
THE CLOTHES--THERE'S LIKE--
BESIDES BEING EXPENSIVE,
THEY'RE SOME
OF THE NEATEST CLOTHES.
Tyra: HELLO!
Shannon: BONJOUR.
Tyra: AS YOU GUYS KNOW,
PARIS IS THE FASHION CAPITAL
OF THE WORLD
AND THE FASHION CAPITAL
OF COUTURE MODELING.
COUTURE IS THE EPITOME
OF FASHION.
A LOT OF TIMES COUTURE CLOTHING
WILL BE ONE OF A KIND.
YOU GUYS NOTICE HOW I HAVE
YOUR HAIR PULLED BACK IN A BUN.
IN FRANCE, THAT'S CALLED
A CHIGNON.
A CHIGNON IS THE MOST ELEGANT
WAY TO WEAR YOUR HAIR,
AND IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT YOUR HAIR IN NO WAY
DISTRACTS FROM THE CLOTHES,
AND TOMORROW YOU'LL BE TESTED
ON YOUR ABILITY
TO CARRY YOURSELF
IN A COUTURE SITUATION.
TODAY YOU'RE GONNA MEET
THE ARTISTIC DIRECTOR OF CARVEN.
PASCAL? (speaks French)
Pascal: WELCOME.
WELCOME TO CARVEN
AND WELCOME TO PARIS.
WELCOME TO THE MAGICAL WORLD
OF HAUTE COUTURE.
♪♪♪
Tyra: MUCH BETTER.
Shannon: YOU GOTTA
BE KIDDING ME.
I'M WEARING THESE DRESSES.
THESE DRESSES ARE PROBABLY
MORE EXPENSIVE THAN EVERYTHING
THAT I OWN PERSONALLY.
Adrianne: THE GOWN
WAS, LIKE, A $20,000 GOWN.
HOW ARE YOU NOT GONNA LIKE
SOME GOWN THAT'S WORTH MORE
THAN YOUR HOUSE AND YOUR CAR?
Pascal: THEY'RE ALL VERY
PROFESSIONAL.
I THINK IT WILL BE TOUGH
TO FIND THE WINNER.
Shannon: THERE'S ONLY
ONE WINNER, AND SO WHO KNOWS?
IT'S GETTING PRETTY CLOSE,
AND HOPEFULLY, YOU KNOW,
I WILL MAKE IT TO THE TOP.
Pascal: GIVE YOU
A SMALL SOUVENIR OF CARVEN.
Shannon: OH,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
(gasps) I SPRAYED THIS ON ME
WHEN I FIRST CAME IN.
THANK YOU.
MERCI BEAUCOUP.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: "TOMORROW IS
YOUR DAY.
YOU HAVE FROM 10 TO 3 TO ENJOY
PARIS AND ALL THE SPLENDORS
IT HAS TO OFFER."
Elyse: WE GOT A TYRA MAIL
SAYING THAT THE NEXT DAY
WE WOULD HAVE SOME FREE TIME TO
DO WHATEVER WE WANTED ALL DAY.
Adrianne: EIFFEL TOWER,
MOTHER...
Shannon: SHOPPING.
Adrianne: YOU GUYS
WANNA GO SHOPPING?
I REALLY DON'T LIKE TO SHOP,
AND IT GETS REALLY OLD
AFTER, LIKE, AN HOUR.
Shannon: I THOUGHT
YOU WANTED TO GO.
Adrianne: I DON'T HAVE MONEY
TO GO SHOPPING.
I JUST WANNA GO SEE
JIM MORRISON'S GRAVE.
Robin: WHO IS JIM MORRIS,
ADRIANNE?
Adrianne: HE IS
THE LEAD SINGER OF THE DOORS,
ONE OF THE MOST INFLUENTIAL
BANDS THAT HAS EVER EXISTED
ON THE FACE OF THE EARTH.
Elyse: ADRIANNE WANTED
TO GO SEE JIM MORRISON'S GRAVE,
AND SHE WANTED TO GO UP
THE TOP OF THE EIFFEL TOWER,
AND ROBIN AND SHANNON
WANTED TO GO SHOPPING.
Shannon: SHE'S WILLING
TO GO SHOPPING WITH US.
WE SHOULD DO SOMETHING
FOR HER, TOO.
Elyse: WE HAVE TO COMPROMISE
SO WE CAN STAY TOGETHER,
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO
SPLIT OFF INTO TWO GROUPS.
Robin: I WANNA GO SHOPPING.
Elyse: I THINK
WE CAN ALL COMPROMISE
SO WE CAN STAY TOGETHER.
Shannon: ROBIN DID NOT
WANNA BUDGE.
SHE DID NOT WANNA GO
ALONG WITH HER.
Elyse: SO SHE'S GONNA HAVE TO
COMPROMISE AND GO SHOPPING
WITH US, AND WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO COMPROMISE
AND GO TO THE GRAVE WITH HER.
Robin: AND I SAID
I WANNA GO SHOPPING.
Elyse: YOU'RE NOT WILLING
TO GO TO JIM MORRISON'S GRAVE
FOR ADRIANNE?
Robin: THIS CONVERSATION
CAN GO ON ALL NIGHT.
Elyse: BECAUSE
YOU WON'T COMPROMISE.
Robin: RESPECT ME WHEN I SAY
THAT I DON'T WANNA GO SEE
THE GRAVE.
JUST RESPECT ME FOR THAT,
JUST LIKE I RESPECT YOU.
Adrianne: I DIDN'T WANNA
LISTEN TO WHAT THAT BITCH
HAD TO SAY.
SHE WAS--SHE'S PSYCHOTIC.
Robin: I SAID
I WANNA GO SHOPPIN'.
SHANNON SAID
SHE WANNA GO SHOPPIN'.
Elyse: IT JUST SUCKS THAT I'M
THE ONE WHO HAS TO COMPROMISE
AND YOU GUYS DON'T.
Robin: I DON'T GO SEE GRAVES.
JUST LIKE YOU DON'T BELIEVE
IN GOD, I DON'T GO SEE GRAVES.
I DON'T TRY TO MAKE YOU
BELIEVE IN GOD, DO I?
Elyse: I GOT REALLY UPSET
WHEN I SAW THIS STUBBORN,
BITCHY SIDE OF ROBIN.
I SORT OF FLED AWAY FROM HER.
Adrianne: WHAT?
Elyse: SHE'S SUCH A BITCH.
Adrianne: WHO IS A BITCH?
Elyse: (sniffles) ROBIN.
Adrianne: I JUST--
DUDE, SERIOUSLY--
Elyse: SHE'S SO MEAN TO YOU,
AND SHE'S SO MEAN TO ME.
I THINK I WAS CRYING
MAINLY OUT OF FRUSTRATION,
BECAUSE ROBIN
WOULDN'T SEE THINGS MY WAY
AND WAS BEING SO INTOLERANT.
IT REALLY PISSED ME OFF.
Robin: IT'S FOUR PEOPLE
WITH FOUR DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT THEY WANNA DO
AND HAVING TO COMPROMISE IT
INTO TWO GROUPS.
IT'S NOT DUMB.
IT'S JUST CALLED
A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION,
AND YOU TRY TO MAKE
THE BEST OF IT.
Adrianne: ONE DAY
SHE'S GONNA GO AGAINST SOMEBODY
THAT DOES NOT CARE
HOW MUCH MONEY YOU HAVE
OR HOW MUCH MOMMY AND DADDY
HAVE GIVEN YOU,
AND SHE'S GONNA GET HER...
THAT'S JUST HOW IT IS.
THE WORD SAYS THAT
IF YOU ARE STANDING THERE
AND SOMEBODY ASKS YOU
FOR YOUR COAT,
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO GIVE IT,
YOU KNOW?
'CAUSE YOU'RE A "CHRISTIAN."
CHRISTIANS ARE NOT SELFISH.
Elyse: SHE DON'T GO SEE
GRAVES.
Adrianne: SHE DOESN'T SEEM
VERY CHRIST-LIKE TO ME.
IN FACT, I THINK SHE SECRETLY
WORSHIPS THE DEVIL.
ALL THIS STUFF
SHE'S PRETENDING TO BE--
IF, YOU KNOW, THERE REALLY IS
THIS BIG, WONDERFUL MAN
IN THE SKY,
THEN HE'S GONNA WHUP HER ASS
WHEN SHE GETS UP THERE.
Elyse: I WAS TRYING
TO KEEP IT FROM BECOMING
YOU AND ME
VERSUS THE TWO OF THEM,
BUT THAT'S IT.
♪♪♪
Elyse: OH, LOOK,
IT'S THAT WAY.
AFTER THE FIGHT
IN THE HOTEL ROOM,
OUR GROUP COMPLETELY POLARIZED
INTO US VERSUS THEM.
ADRIANNE WANTED TO GO SEE
JIM MORRISON'S GRAVE.
Adrianne: OOH.
DISCOTHEQUE.
Elyse: AND ROBIN AND SHANNON
WANTED TO GO SHOPPING.
Shannon: THIS IS
GONNA BE FUN.
Robin: THIS IS OUR--
ONLY OUR ONE DAY IN PARIS
TO GET WHATEVER WE WANTED
TO GET DONE DONE.
IT'S BEST JUST TO SPLIT UP.
Shannon: O EST
LE CHAMPS ELYSEES?
MERCI.
Robin: YOU JUST RUN ACROSS.
Shannon: YOU CAN'T
RUN ACROSS THERE.
Robin: YEAH, YOU CAN.
Shannon: I AIN'T
RUNNING ACROSS.
Robin: COME ON, COME ON.
Shannon: YOU CAN'T...
Adrianne: THIS IS
JIM MORRISON'S GRAVE, DUDE.
THIS IS SO COOL.
ELYSE DIDN'T WANNA GO SEE
JIM MORRISON'S GRAVE,
BUT SHE SACRIFICED THAT FOR ME,
AND JUST LIKE, THAT'S COOL.
DUDE, ELYSE, I NEED
A BOYFRIEND FOR THIS PLACE.
WILL YOU BE MY BOYFRIEND?
Elyse: YES, MADAME.
Robin: I THINK IT'S THIS WAY.
COME ON.
Shannon: WHERE IS
THE MONUMENT?
WHERE ARE YOU GOING?
Elyse: IS THIS IT?
Adrianne: THIS HAS TO BE IT.
YOU WANNA LOOK AT THOSE SIGNS?
Elyse: I DON'T KNOW.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
Adrianne: THIS IS
SO BEAUTIFUL.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: WE'RE LOST
IN THE GRAVEYARD.
Elyse: DID THEY MOVE
JIM MORRISON'S BODY?
Adrianne: OFFICIALLY LOST.
WE WENT TO SEE
JIM MORRISON'S GRAVE,
AND WE ENDED UP LOST.
BUT WE WERE JUST HAVING FUN
WITH EACH OTHER.
IT WAS FUN.
Elyse: LOOK,
THERE'S A PHOTO PLACE.
LET'S GO IN THERE.
(laughing)
Elyse: WE DECIDED
TO SEPARATE.
ADRIANNE AND I DID OUR THING.
ROBIN AND SHANNON
WENT TO THE GAP,
AND IN RETROSPECT,
I DON'T KNOW WHY
I WANTED THE FOUR OF US
TO STAY TOGETHER AT ALL.
Robin: DO YOU REMEMBER
THE NAME OF THE HOTEL?
DID YOU WRITE IT DOWN?
I THOUGHT I ASKED YOU
TO GO AND GET THE NAME OF IT.
Shannon: I HAVE IT
ON THAT PIECE OF PAPER,
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHERE I PUT IT.
Robin: HERE, COME ON.
Shannon: SOME THINGS
ROBIN DOES MIGHT...
GET ON MY NERVES
AFTER A LITTLE WHILE.
Robin: COME ON, SHANNON.
YOU GOTTA GO FASTER.
Shannon: OKAY, IT SAYS,
"YOU HAVE UNTIL 4 P.M.
TO GET READY FOR
A SPECTACULAR NIGHT OUT."
IT SAYS BE READY AT 4 P.M.,
HAIR AND MAKEUP DONE.
IT'S FOR
A SPECTACULAR NIGHT OUT.
♪♪♪
Shannon: ANYONE KNOW
WHAT TIME IT IS?
Elyse: YEAH, IT IS--
Adrianne: WE HAVE 15 MINUTES.
Shannon: YOU'RE LYING.
Adrianne and Elyse: NOPE.
Shannon: HOLY POOP.
Robin: CAN YOU POP THE TRUNK?
♪♪♪
Pascal: WELCOME BACK.
Elyse: THANK YOU.
Shannon: I'M GONNA BE SCARED
TO WEAR ONE OF YOUR DRESSES.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: THEY GAVE ME
THIS GOWN.
THIS GOWN--LIKE, MY BOOBS
WERE HANGING OUT THE SIDE
AND IN THE MIDDLE.
Robin: THE COUTURE CHALLENGE
WAS TO GO OUT WITH SOME MEN
AND HAVE THEM JUDGE US
ON BEING A LADY.
WOMEN THAT WEAR COUTURE
ARE SOCIALITES.
THEY ARE A LADY IN EVERY SENSE.
Shannon: HI.
Elyse: WE'VE BEEN LIVING
IN REALLY CLOSE QUARTERS
IN OUR MODEL APARTMENT,
AND EVERY SINGLE GIRL
IS FANTASIZING ABOUT SPENDING
A NIGHT AWAY FROM THERE.
Shannon: ARE YOU EXCITED?
ARE YOU EXCITED?
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH, YEAH,
I'M SO EXCITED.
Adrianne: I FEEL SO GOOD
IN THIS.
I FEEL LIKE SOMEBODY ELSE.
Shannon: THERE IT IS.
"FUGUENOT"...
Elyse: WHERE?
Shannon: "FOGO-NOT"...
FOUGU-NUT'S.
Adrianne: FOUGU-NUT'S!
Elyse: I THINK IT'S, LIKE,
FON-GWE?
Man: WELCOME
TO THE FOUQUET'S,
THE OLDER RESTAURANT IN PARIS.
WILL YOU FOLLOW ME, PLEASE?
Shannon: HI.
Adrian: HI. HOW ARE YOU?
I'M ADRIAN. NICE TO MEET YOU.
Shannon: I'M SHANNON.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
Elyse: ELYSE.
Adrianne: I LIKED
THE ADRIAN DUDE, JUST, WELL,
BECAUSE HIS NAME IS ADRIAN.
Shannon: SHANNON.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
Man: NICE TO MEET YOU.
THEY WERE GONNA JUDGE US ON
HOW WE ACTED LIKE A LADY,
SO I WAS LIKE, YOU KNOW,
I CAN DO THIS.
I'M, YOU KNOW, I'M A LADY.
♪♪♪
Adrian: FOIE GRAS.
Shannon: FOIE GRAS. OKAY.
Adrian: THEY ARE GOOSE
OR DUCK LIVER.
Man: ARE YOU WILLING
TO TRY IT?
Adrianne: OKAY.
LET'S SEE HOW THIS IS.
Man: BON APPéTIT.
Shannon: SO THIS IS
OUR DINNER?
Adrian: THIS IS IT.
Elyse: I ATE EVERYTHING
I WAS SERVED
JUST TO TRY EVERYTHING.
Robin: THE FOOD WAS NASTY.
YOU KNOW, IT WASN'T LIKE ALL,
YOU KNOW, IT WAS CRACKED UP
TO BE.
Man: YOU LIKE IT?
Robin: IT'S DIFFERENT.
IT DOESN'T REALLY--
Man: IT'S DIFFERENT.
Adrianne: ROBIN WAS BEING
A BITCH, BITCH, BITCH,
BITCH, BITCH.
SHANNON'S JUST LIKE...
SO I WAS LIKE, ALL RIGHT,
I'M GONNA NAB THIS OPPORTUNITY.
Shannon: THIS PLACE IS BIG.
Elyse: AFTER WE LEFT
THE RESTAURANT,
WE WENT TO SEE A BALLET
AT THE OPERA HOUSE IN PARIS.
Adrianne: I DON'T LIKE BALLET.
IT'S LIKE ALL THESE GUYS
ARE LIKE... (humming)
AND DANCING AROUND.
IT'S LIKE, OH, MY GOD.
BUT I DIDN'T SIT THERE
AND BITCH AND COMPLAIN.
I JUST TRIED TO KEEP ACTING
LIKE A LADY.
ARE OUR ACCENTS UGLY
TO YOU GUYS, HONESTLY?
AMERICAN ACCENTS--ARE THEY UGLY?
BE... HONEST.
Man: NO, IT'S NOT UGLY.
YOU JUST GOTTA GET USED TO IT.
Adrianne: IS IT HARSH?
Adrian: (Southern accent)
WELL, I WAS BORN DOWN SOUTH
IN TEXAS.
Man: LET'S GO AND PARTY
ALL NIGHT LONG.
Robin: THESE CAT DADDY
LUSTFUL TYPE OF MEN WERE THERE.
YOU COULD TELL
BY THEIR CONVERSATION,
THEY WANTED TO SOCIALIZE,
AND THAT'S THE REASON WHY
I TUNED THEM OUT.
Adrianne: THAT'S ALL SHE DID
FOR, LIKE, FOUR HOURS
WITH THESE DUDES,
WAS READ THE BIBLE.
♪♪♪
Shannon: OH, PRETTY.
WOW.
LOOK, CHOCOLATE.
Adrianne: OH, MY...
Shannon: OH, MY WORD!
Shannon: BEAUTIFUL.
Elyse: IT'S HUGE.
WHEN I SAW
THE PRESIDENTIAL SUITE,
UM, I WAS REALLY ATTRACTED
TO IT, BUT I KNEW
THAT EITHER WAY,
SEPARATING MYSELF AND ADRIANNE
FROM ROBIN AND SHANNON
WOULD HAVE BEEN A PRIZE.
Shannon: I BET THIS BED
COULD FIT ALL OF US.
(laughter)
Shannon: NO, REALLY.
NO LYIN'.
Adrianne: WE STEPPED IN,
AND IT WAS JUST IMMACULATE.
IT WAS A PALACE--
A PALACE THAT HAD "ADRIANNE"
WRITTEN ALL OVER IT.
Shannon: OH, MY WORD!
Adrianne: OHH!
All: CHEERS.
Elyse: I THOUGHT THAT ROBIN
WOULD EASILY DOMINATE
THE ETIQUETTE COMPETITION,
BUT, UM, SHE WASN'T WILLING
TO MAKE CONVERSATION AT ALL,
SO I THINK THAT, UM,
DEFINITELY DETRACTED
FROM HER PERFORMANCE
IN THE COMPETITION.
Man: ALL RIGHT, LADIES,
WE CAME TO A POINT WHERE WE
HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION ABOUT
WHO'S GONNA BE THE WINNER.
WOULD YOU EXCUSE US FOR, UH,
SOME MINUTES?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
♪♪♪
Man: LET'S START WITH ROBIN.
Adrian: I WOULDN'T VOTE
FOR ROBIN.
SHE DIDN'T LIVE UP
TO THIS SOCIAL SCENE
IN TERMS OF THE DISCUSSION
OF BEING INTERESTED
IN OTHER PEOPLE'S INTERESTS.
Man #2: ROBIN, YES.
SHE DIDN'T EAT ANYTHING.
Man: BY FRENCH STANDARDS,
IT'S A PROBLEM.
All: (laughing)
Man #3: ADRIANNE IS
VERY FUNNY, BRILLIANT, SMILEY.
Adrian: I WOULD SAY
SHE'S MAYBE LESS CLEVER
OR LESS WITTY THAN ELYSE.
Man #2: I LOVE ELYSE,
BECAUSE SHE IS
THE CHARMING GIRL.
Adrian: I THINK OF THE FOUR,
SHE'S VERY INTERESTING.
SHE HAS A LOT TO SAY.
Man: SHANNON.
Man #2: I LOVE HER FACE,
HER TEETH.
Adrian: BEAUTIFULLY DRESSED.
I THINK SHE DID A GREAT JOB
WEARING THAT DRESS
AND LIVING UP TO THE STANDARDS.
Man #3: I THINK SOMETHING,
UH, SOMETHING, UH, COLD.
Man: SO WE'VE COME
TO A CONCLUSION.
Man: ELYSE, SHANNON,
ROBIN, ADRIANNE,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THIS WONDERFUL EVENING.
AS WE SAY, ALL GOOD THING
COME TO AN END.
SO WE HAD THE DIFFICULT MISSION
TO SELECT ONE PERSON, ONE GIRL,
AND THE PERSON WE'VE ATTAINED
IS ADRIANNE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO GIVE
ONE NAME AMONG YOUR FRIEND.
WHO'S GONNA BE STAYING WITH YOU?
Adrianne: ELYSE.
Man: CONGRATULATIONS.
Shannon: OH, 'LYSA!
Man #2: CAN WE GIVE YOU
A KISS?
(laughter)
Adrianne: LOOK AT THIS SUITE!
SUITE!
I TOLD YOU, I RUINED YOUR DAY.
I WAS SO SORRY.
I WAS SO SORRY,
BUT JIM MORRISON IS SO COOL.
Shannon: I THOUGHT
ROBIN WAS GONNA WIN IT BECAUSE
SHE'S BEEN TO, LIKE,
ETIQUETTE CLASS.
YOU KNOW, SHE CAN JUST--
SHE'S GOT THAT WHOLE THING.
♪♪♪
Elyse: ADRIANNE AND I
HAD A LOT OF FUN
IN THE PRESIDENTIAL SUITE
AFTER OUR ESCORTS LEFT.
Adrianne: LET'S GO EAT
SOME MORE OF THAT CAKE.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I KNOW HOW TO WORK THE MEN!
Shannon: WE'RE BACK!
(chuckles)
Robin: ADRIANNE WAS, UM,
VERY, VERY, VERY, VERY, VERY
FRIENDLY.
SHE WORKED IT,
AND SHE GOT THE PRIZE.
Adrianne: ♪ I LIVE ♪
♪ IN A MANSION IN PARIS ♪
♪ I LIVE IN A MANSION ♪
♪ IN PARIS ♪♪
Elyse: WE ATE A BUNCH
OF CHOCOLATE CAKE,
AND WE ATE A LOT OF FRUIT,
AND WE WERE SO HAPPY
TO BE AWAY
FROM ROBIN AND SHANNON.
Robin: WELL,
MAMA GOT TO REST.
Adrianne: I FEEL LIKE
A QUEEN.
Adrianne: DUDE,
THEY HAVE SET THIS UP
FOR OUR ROMANTIC NIGHT TOGETHER,
ELYSE.
DO YOU HAVE YOUR TOP ON?
Elyse: ME? YEAH.
Adrianne: SHOULD
I PUT MINE ON?
Elyse: DO YOU HAVE
YOUR TOP OFF?
Elyse: YES. OH.
Adrianne:
BASICALLY JUST TRIED TO ACT
VERY LADYLIKE,
TO HAVE A LOT OF GRACE,
AND IT WAS EVERYTHING I'M NOT.
I GUESS I PROVED
THAT I CAN BE A BROAD.
GOOD NIGHT, SLUT HO.
Elyse: GOOD NIGHT.
♪♪♪
Elyse: WE GOT A TYRA MAIL
SAYING THAT WE WOULD BE DOING
AN ADVERTISEMENT FOR DIAMONDS.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: THIS PLACE IS NUTS.
Jay: HEY, GIRLS,
SO TODAY I'M GONNA BE WORKING
WITH YOU WITH MAKEUP
AND DIRECTING YOU ON SET.
WE'RE IN BUDDHA BAR RESTAURANT,
WHICH IS ONE OF PARIS'
MOST FAMOUS RESTAURANTS.
IT'S VERY CHIC.
A LOT OF CELEBRITIES COME HERE,
SO NOW YOU GUYS
CAN SAY YOU'VE BEEN HERE.
WE'RE HERE WITH
THE SIRENA COLLECTION,
WHICH IS JEWELRY, SO YOU KNOW
YOU'RE MODELING DIAMONDS.
COOL, RIGHT?
Shannon: YEAH.
Jay: OKAY, THE LOOK, THOUGH,
WE'RE GONNA HAVE VERY STRONG,
KIND OF EDGY, GREASY,
KIND OF BLACK CHARCOAL EYES,
AND THE BODY'S GONNA BE
REALLY GREASED,
AND WE'RE GONNA SPRAY WATER,
AND WE'RE GONNA WET YOUR HAIR,
AND YOU'RE POSING NUDE.
(crickets chirping)
Shannon: HE SAID
THAT WE WOULD BE POSING NUDE,
AND I WAS LIKE, OKAY, YOU KNOW,
"KEEP ON GOIN'.
I KNOW YOU'RE JUST KIDDIN',"
BUT HE WAS TELLING THE TRUTH.
I WAS LIKE, OH, NO!
Jay: THE REASON
WE'RE ADDING THE EXTRA HAIR
IS SO THE HAIR CAN COME DOWN.
YOUR BREASTS WILL BE COVERED.
AS I EXPECTED,
ADRIANNE AND ELYSE WERE JUST
LIKE, "OH, OKAY. NO PROBLEM."
ROBIN--I SAW
HER WHOLE FACE CHANGE.
SHE WENT GRAY.
SHANNON, I FELT,
MIGHT BE ABLE TO DO THIS.
WE HAVE PATRICK KATZMAN.
HE'S GONNA TALK TO YOU GUYS
ABOUT THE LOOK.
IT'S GONNA BE VERY MOODY,
THE LIGHTING, EVERYTHING.
SO HERE HE IS.
Patrick: HELLO.
HOW YOU GUYS DOING?
SO TODAY WE'RE GONNA GO FOR
SOMETHING KIND OF DRAMATIC,
VERY STRETCHED-OUT POSES,
EXAGGERATING YOUR BODY,
THE SHAPE.
SO DON'T WORRY.
WE'RE GONNA MAKE--DO A LOT OF
LIKE HANDS ACROSS THE CHEST,
HANDS ACROSS THE LOWER BODY,
SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT BEING EXPOSED
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
Jay: IT JUST NEEDS TO BE
REALLY, REALLY STRONG.
THINK, JUST WILD.
THE ORDER IS GONNA BE ADRIANNE,
ELYSE, ROBIN AND SHANNON,
ALL RIGHT?
ARE YOU READY TO START?
Patrick: LET'S DO IT.
Jay: HAIR AND MAKEUP?
Adrianne: YES.
WHAT SHANNON AND ROBIN THINK
THAT THE INDUSTRY DOESN'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH BEING SEXUAL
OR LUSTFUL OR NAKED--
THAT JUST ENSURES THAT
ELYSE AND I WILL BE HEAD TO HEAD
AT THE END.
♪♪♪
Jay: SPRAY HER WATER--
TONS OF WATER.
Elyse: ADRIANNE SPREADS OPEN
AND LETS THE MAKEUP ARTISTS
OIL HER DOWN,
AND AT THAT POINT,
I THINK SHANNON STARTED CRYING.
Shannon: A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE DIFFERENT.
A LOT OF GIRLS WILL DO ANYTHING.
Robin: YEAH.
SERVING THE LORD AIN'T EASY,
BUT IN THE END,
YOU ALWAYS COME ON TOP.
Patrick: NICE.
BEAUTIFUL. BEAUTIFUL.
Adrianne: MY IDEA OF
THE SHOOT WAS LOOK DAMN GOOD.
COVER YOUR BODY PARTS,
LOOK LIKE YOU'RE BUCK NAKED
AND COVERED IN DIAMONDS.
Jay: WE FIRST STARTED
WITH ADRIANNE.
ANY DIRECTION
THE PHOTOGRAPHER GAVE HER
OR THAT I GAVE HER
SHE WENT WITH.
SHE'S NEVER A PROBLEM.
Patrick: ADRIANNE WAS
A REAL PLEASURE TO START WITH.
SHE HAD A LOT OF CONFIDENCE.
SHE KNEW THE POSITIONS.
SHE LOOKS RIGHT INTO THE CAMERA,
AND IT REALLY HELPS
SHOOTING A GIRL LIKE THAT.
IT REALLY SHOWS
ON THE FINAL IMAGE.
Jay: I WANTED ROBIN
AND SHANNON TO SEE
THE MORE INTIMATE SETTING
WE HAD CREATED
FOR THE REST OF THE SHOTS.
I WANTED THEM TO TRUST ME
AND UNDERSTAND THAT
WHAT I WAS GOING TO DO FOR THEM
WOULD NOT EXPOSE THEM
IN ANY WAY.
WE ARE JUST RESETTING
FOR ELYSE'S SHOT, WHICH IS
JUST OVER THERE BY THE BAR.
I JUST WANTED YOU BOTH TO SEE
THAT IT'S A LITTLE MORE QUAINT.
IT'S A LITTLE LESS OPEN,
AND WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA
BLOCK OFF SOME OF THESE ARCHWAYS
SO THAT IT'S COMPLETELY PRIVATE
FROM DOWNSTAIRS.
I JUST HAVE TO REALLY STRESS
WHAT THE OUTCOME OF THE SHOOT
IS SUPPOSED TO BE,
AND THAT THE OUTCOME
OF THE SHOOT IS
THE ILLUSION OF NUDITY,
EVEN THOUGH YOU'RE NOT NUDE.
WHAT WE HAVE FOR AN OPTION
FOR COVERING UP
IS THE UNDERWEAR,
AND WE GOT THE BAND,
WHICH WE CAN DOUBLE-BAND AROUND.
SO WE CAN GO OVER ONCE
AND THEN GO BACK AROUND
A SECOND TIME TO MAKE IT WIDE.
TELL ME YOUR CONCERNS.
IS IT THE ILLUSION OF NUDITY
THAT BOTHERS YOU?
Robin: ME PERSONALLY, IT, UM,
THE BEING NUDE, FIRST OFF,
AND HAVING PEOPLE SEE THAT.
Jay: BUT YOU DON'T HAVE
TO BE NUDE.
YOU KNOW, LIKE WE SAID,
WE CAN DOUBLE-BAND YOUR TOP.
Robin: AND THEN, TOO, IS
THE ILLUSION IS REALLY NOT
REALLY SITTING WELL
WITH ME, EITHER.
Jay: THE ILLUSION
BOTHERS YOU?
Robin: IT DOESN'T SIT WELL.
MY BODY IS SACRED,
AND IT'S MINE, AND, UM,
MY RELIGION TEACHES ME
THAT MY BODY'S A TEMPLE.
Jay: SHANNON?
Shannon: UM,
I WANNA TRY IT ON,
TO SEE WHAT THE BAND LOOKS LIKE.
Jay: YOU WANNA TRY THE BAND?
Shannon: YEAH.
I WANTED TO TRY--AT LEAST
TRY IT OUT 'CAUSE YOU NEVER KNOW
UNTIL YOU TRY SOMETHING OUT.
Jay: AND WHAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO DO?
Robin: I WANNA TRY
THE BAND, TOO.
Jay: THEY'RE
A LITTLE APPREHENSIVE.
REMEMBER WHEN WE WERE AT CARVEN
THE OTHER DAY
AND YOU GUYS WERE FITTING
AND I WAS SITTING ON THE SIDE?
DID YOU KNOW WHAT ROBIN DID?
NOW IT'S SO FUNNY THAT SHE'S
SO UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THIS.
Elyse: WHY?
Jay: SHE WENT, "MR. JAY."
AND I WENT, "UH-HUH?"
♪♪♪
Adrianne: I ALWAYS SEE
THAT ELYSE IS DOING
A LITTLE BIT BETTER THAN I,
AND IT JUST DRIVES ME
TO TRY TO WHUP HER ASS.
Elyse: I WASN'T UNCOMFORTABLE
AT ALL DURING THE ACTUAL SHOOT.
I DON'T THINK THE PHOTOGRAPHER
IS GONNA MANIPULATE
ANY OF THE IMAGES HE HAD
TO MAKE PORN.
Jay: ELYSE, I FEEL LIKE,
IS SHE'S STARTING TO FEEL
THE COMPETITION WITH ADRIANNE.
SHE GOT UP ON THAT BAR,
AND I MEAN, THE LOOK THAT WAS
COMING OUT OF HER EYES--
IT WAS INCREDIBLE.
♪ I CAN SEE THE HURT ♪
♪ IN YOUR EYES ♪
♪ THE PAIN, THE TEARS ♪
♪ YOU'RE RUNNING AFTER LOVE ♪
♪ BUT BACK DOWN IN FEAR ♪
♪ I CAN SEE THE HURT ♪♪
Patrick: ALL RIGHT,
WE GOT IT.
(knocks on door)
Robin: UM, I'M
NOT GONNA DO IT.
Jay: YOU'RE NOT GONNA DO IT?
Shannon: YEAH,
I DECIDED THAT, TOO.
I WAS TRYING TO IMAGINE
THE PICTURE IN MY HEAD--
WHAT I WOULD LOOK LIKE,
AND IT WOULD JUST NOT BE ME.
Robin: RIGHT.
Jay: IT WOULDN'T BE YOU.
ARE YOU GOING WITH ROBIN
ARE YOU JUST KINDA...
Shannon: NO,
I'M GOING WITH WHAT I'M FEELING.
SHE'S HER, AND I'M ME.
Robin: YOU'RE LOOKIN' AT
A REPRESENTATIVE
FOR NOT ONLY YOUNG WOMEN
BUT AMERICA AS A WHOLE
AND A WOMAN THAT HAS INTEGRITY.
LAST WEEK IT WAS
BRA AND PANTIES.
I PROBABLY WOULD NEVER DO THAT.
THIS WEEK IS TWO STRANDS
OF RIBBON AND A THONG.
WHAT IS IT GONNA BE NEXT WEEK?
MY GRANDMOTHER USED TO ALWAYS
TELL ME, "IF YOU DON'T STAND
FOR SOMETHING,
YOU'LL FALL FOR ANYTHING,"
SO THIS STAND RIGHT HERE
I'M TAKING MIGHT MAKE ME
BE ELIMINATED,
SO IF MY TIME HERE IS UP,
THEN I'M OKAY WITH IT.
Jay: MM-HMM.
Robin: I'M OKAY WITH THAT.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: I LOVED PARIS.
I LOVE PARIS SO MUCH.
Robin: PARIS HAS LEFT
A BITTERSWEET TASTE IN MY MOUTH.
FRANCE IS GORGEOUS,
BUT MY EXPERIENCES IN FRANCE--
THEY WEREN'T THE MOST HAPPIEST.
♪♪♪
(horn honks)
Shannon: WOW!
WE ARE ALL IN ONE ROOM NOW.
Adrianne: SPECTACULAR.
Tyra: MODELS JUST
STARTING OUT
SHARE REALLY CRAMPED QUARTERS,
SO I REDUCED THE PENTHOUSE
DOWN TO JUST ONE ROOM.
Shannon: WE HAVE MAIL.
"WELCOME BACK.
MILAN IS YOUR NEW HOME.
UNPACK AND SETTLE IN.
TOMORROW THREE OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE ON TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED."
Adrianne: TOMORROW.
Elyse: TOMORROW.
Shannon: I DON'T KNOW HOW
THAT PHOTO SHOOT THAT
I DID NOT DO WILL AFFECT ME.
Robin: I NEVER HAVE
ANY CONCERNS, BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT IT'S NOT IN MY HANDS.
IT'S IN GOD'S HANDS.
Elyse: I THINK THAT
ROBIN AND SHANNON'S DECISION
WILL DEFINITELY AFFECT THEM
ADVERSELY IN THE COMPETITION.
Adrianne: SHOULD I SLEEP
ON KESSE'S BED?
Shannon: YEAH, YOU HAVE TO.
Adrianne: I WAS JUST ASKING.
ROBIN--SHE'S GONNA START
REALIZING THAT--
HERE COMES THE QUEEN.
BETTER MOVE OVER,
'CAUSE THIS IS MY HOUSE NOW.
WELCOME HOME.
♪♪♪
Tyra: HELLO, LADIES.
NOW IT'S TIME TO MAKE
OUR SEVENTH CUT.
ONLY THREE OF YOU WILL REMAIN
ON THE QUEST TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE WINNER WILL RECEIVE
A REVLON CONTRACT, A CONTRACT
WITH WILHELMINA MODELS, INC.
AND A FASHION SPREAD
IN "MARIE CLAIRE" MAGAZINE.
AS USUAL, WE HAVE
OUR PANEL OF JUDGES.
FIRST, WE HAVE JANICE DICKINSON,
(chuckling) ONE OF THE FIRST
SUPERMODELS EVER.
Janice: I AM
THE FIRST SUPERMODEL.
Tyra: WE HAVE BEAU QUILLIAN.
BEAU'S THE FASHION EDITOR
AT "MARIE CLAIRE."
WE HAVE KIMORA LEE SIMMONS.
KIMORA'S THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR
AND OWNER OF BABY PHAT FASHIONS,
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
MR. DEREK KHAN.
DEREK HAS BEEN YOUR STYLIST
THROUGHOUT THIS WHOLE JOURNEY,
AND HE'S ALWAYS FASHION-FORWARD,
OR BACKWARDS, AS YOU CAN SEE.
DEREK HAS COME UP
WITH A TEST FOR YOU TODAY.
Derek: I'M GOING TO SEND YOU
UPSTAIRS TO DRESS
IN COUTURE GARMENTS.
I HAVE BEAUTIFUL ACCESSORIES.
I HAVE LOVELY SHOES.
I HAVE HATS. I GOT THE GLOVES.
I GOT IT ALL.
AND IN TEN MINUTES,
I WANT YOU TO COME BACK HERE
AND SHOW ME WHAT YOU'VE LEARNED
IN PARIS, OKAY?
♪♪♪
Robin: GO LIKE THAT?
Shannon: YEAH.
YEAH, MINE'S A DRESS.
Adrianne: GIRL, I'M GOING
DOWN THERE, LIKE, NAKED.
Shannon: ARE THESE
THE ONLY SHOES I HAVE LEFT?
Adrianne: THESE AREN'T
GONNA FIT.
Tyra: SEND ELYSE IN, PLEASE.
ELYSE!
YOU LOOK FABULOUS!
Janice: BRAVA, DARLING!
BRAVA!
Beau: I THINK IT LOOKS GREAT.
Elyse: THANK YOU.
Tyra: YOU HAD
A NUDE PHOTO SHOOT
WITH THE PHOTOGRAPHER
PATRICK KATZMAN.
WE FOUND YOUR TOP PICTURE,
AND HERE IT IS.
I THINK YOU LOOK SO SEXY,
AND YOUR BOOTY LOOKS
KINDA BIG AND JUICY.
THAT'S GREAT!
Derek: I THINK
SHE LOOKS FAT IN THAT PICTURE.
Tyra: YEAH.
Beau: THIS IS
YOUR FIRST TIME, I'M ASSUMING,
DOING A NUDE PHOTO, AND YOU
DON'T LOOK UNCOMFORTABLE.
YOU DON'T LOOK INTIMIDATED.
Kimora: ABSOLUTELY
GORGEOUS PICTURE,
AND YOUR EYES ARE REALLY
AMAZING.
Tyra: HOW DID YOU FEEL
DOING THE SHOOT?
Elyse: THERE WAS DEFINITELY
A LOT OF TRUST INVOLVED.
IT WAS TOTALLY OBVIOUS
WE WEREN'T MAKING PORN.
Janice: I SEE
AN INCREDIBLE, CONFIDENT WOMAN
THAT OWNS THE PHOTOGRAPH.
IT LOOKS GREAT.
Tyra: NOTHING ELSE? OKAY.
HELLO, SHANNON.
Shannon: HI.
Tyra: WHAT'S THE ONE THING
THAT THE DESIGNERS
AND THE PEOPLE THAT YOU WENT
ON THE GO-SEES WITH IN PARIS
COMPLAINED ABOUT YOUR LOOK?
Shannon: NOT EDGY ENOUGH.
Tyra: WHAT IS THE ONE THING
THAT CAN TAKE YOU
FROM BEING MISS CALIFORNIA GIRL
TO BEING EDGY?
Shannon: SLICKING
MY HAIR BACK.
Tyra: AND SO WHY
DIDN'T YOU DO THAT?
Shannon: I RAN OUT OF TIME.
Tyra: IT'S A LITTLE TOO
CALIFORNIA.
Derek: YOU DON'T HAVE
THAT EXTRA--EXACTLY--
THAT EXTRA PIZZAZZ,
THAT EXTRA GRACE
THAT'S ESSENTIAL.
Tyra: SHANNON, YOU WERE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE A PHOTO SHOOT
WITH PATRICK KATZMAN.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
A SEMI-NUDE SHOOT--
A SIMULATED NUDE.
WE DON'T HAVE A PICTURE FOR YOU.
WHY IS THAT?
Shannon: I NEVER
WANNA POSE NUDE,
NO MATTER HOW MUCH MONEY
OR HOW MUCH, YOU KNOW,
FAME I WOULD GET.
Janice: IF YOU'RE NOT WILLING
TO DO THAT, YOU MIGHT AS WELL
GO WORK AT A CAR FACTORY
OR A BAKERY, BECAUSE THAT'S
PART OF BEING A MODEL.
Beau: DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA
WHAT IT'S LIKE BACKSTAGE
AT A FASHION SHOW?
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT 30 GIRLS
THAT HAVE TO JUST STRIP
COMPLETELY NAKED.
Tyra: I DON'T POSE NUDE,
BUT I WILL SIMULATE IT,
MEANING A G-STRING,
AND THEN LATER THEY RETOUCH
THE G-STRING OUT ON THE SIDE,
AND TO ME, THAT'S NOT NUDITY.
NOW WHAT DO YOU THINK?
LIKE, DO YOU FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE BITING A MAN'S EAR
OR DOING A PHOTO SHOOT
AND SIMULATING NUDITY?
Shannon: I'D RATHER BITE
A GUY'S EAR THAN, UM, BE NUDE
IN THE SHOT.
Janice: WELL, I WISH THAT
I HAD SEEN YOU SEMI-NUDE.
Derek: I WANTED TO JUDGE
SOME PICTURES, DARLING.
Tyra: THANKS, SHANNON.
HELLO, ADRIANNE.
Derek: HELLO THERE.
OOH. BELLISSIMO. OH.
All: (laughing)
Janice: THERE YOU GO.
WHERE'S THE MAKEUP?
Derek: LET ME SEE YOUR FOOT.
HONEY, WHAT ARE YOU WEARING?
Tyra: WHOO!
Derek: OOH, GIRL.
OH, I LOVE THIS.
WHY DIDN'T YOU PUT
ANY MORE ACCESSORIES?
Adrianne: I FELT LIKE
JUST THE EARRINGS AND THE SHOES
WERE FLASHY ENOUGH TO, LIKE,
PULL OFF SUCH AN EXTREME--
Janice: IT'S
A VERY SOPHISTICATED DRESS.
YOU SHOULD'VE SMACKED ON
A RED MOUTH MAYBE,
OR JUST MADE THE MAKEUP
A LITTLE BIT DARKER.
Tyra: ARE YOU NUDE
UNDER THERE?
Adrianne: YES, MA'AM.
Tyra: YOU HAVE
SOME PANTIES ON?
Adrianne: NO, MA'AM.
Derek: ARE YOU BUTT NAKED?
Tyra: CHILD, YOU BETTER WORK.
Adrianne: NO TIME, MA'AM.
Tyra: I LOVE THE FACT THAT YOU
PULLED THAT HAIR BACK.
YOU LISTENED TO WHAT I SAID--
THAT COUTURE IS ABOUT CHIGNONS
OR SLICKING IT BACK.
YOU HAD A NUDE PHOTO SHOOT.
WE PICKED YOUR TOP PHOTO,
AND HERE IT IS.
JANICE?
Janice: I THINK
THE PHOTOGRAPH IS EXQUISITE.
Derek: THIS IS
SO IN-YOUR-FACE.
THIS IS FABULOUS.
Adrianne: IT WAS
EXCRUCIATING PAIN
HAVING TO, LIKE, ARCH MY BODY
LIKE THAT FOR SO LONG
AND TRY TO KEEP
THE PERFECT BALANCE
WHERE I WOULDN'T FALL.
Kimora: AND YOU PHOTOGRAPH
BEAUTIFULLY.
YOU LOOK GORGEOUS RIGHT NOW,
BUT SOMETIMES
IN YOUR APPEARANCE,
YOU'RE A LITTLE BIT BUFF FOR ME.
Tyra: I LOVE THAT
THIS PICTURE LOOKS LIKE AN AD.
I FEEL LIKE WHATEVER
YOU'RE SELLING,
IT'LL MAKE THE COMPANY
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
I'D SUGGEST THAT THEY GIVE YOU
AS MUCH MONEY AS POSSIBLE.
Adrianne: THANKS, GUYS.
Tyra: THANK YOU.
Janice: BYE-BYE.
Tyra: SEND IN ROBIN, PLEASE.
HI, ROBIN.
Derek: I'M SURPRISED.
THE DRESS--I THINK
THE DRESS ACTUALLY WORKS.
Tyra: I MEAN,
IT LOOKS KIND OF EUROPEAN.
Derek: IT GIVES THE EFFECT,
BUT WHAT I DON'T LOVE
IS THE ACCESSORIES.
Janice: DO YOU MIND
TAKING THE HAT OFF?
Robin: OH, YEAH,
I'LL TAKE IT OFF.
Tyra: I WAS VERY EAGER
TO TALK TO ROBIN
ABOUT HER REFUSAL TO DO
THE SIMULATED NUDE SHOOT,
BECAUSE WHEN THE CAMERAS
WEREN'T ROLLING,
I SAW SOMETHING THAT WAS
VERY OUT OF CHARACTER FOR HER,
AND IT SHOCKED
THE HELL OUT OF ME.
ROBIN, YOU WERE SUPPOSED
TO HAVE A NUDE PHOTO SHOOT.
WE DON'T HAVE A PHOTO FOR YOU
THIS WEEK, AND WHY IS THAT?
Robin: I DIDN'T WANNA FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE.
UM, MY BODY IS MINE.
I JUST DIDN'T THINK THAT,
YOU KNOW, THAT IS WHAT
I NEEDED TO DO
IN ORDER TO GET AHEAD.
Tyra: I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
YOU CAN SAY NO
TO SOMETHING LIKE THAT,
BUT THEN IN THE DRESSING ROOM,
WHEN YOU THINK
NO ONE IS LOOKING,
YOU DIDN'T KNOW MISS TYRA
WAS RIGHT THERE.
I SAW YOU OPEN
THE DRESSING ROOM
AT THE COUTURE HOUSE,
AND YOU WERE NUDE,
AND YOU SHOOK YOUR CHEST AT JAY.
Robin: I SAID, "MR. JAY,"
BECAUSE I SAW HIM
RIGHT THERE IN THE OPENING,
AND I SAID, "MR. JAY,"
LIKE THAT, AND THEN HE SAID--
(gasps) HE LOOKED LIKE, "ROBIN."
Tyra: YOU DID IT LIKE THAT,
ROBIN.
I WAS RIGHT THERE.
WHAT IS THIS PERSON THAT
PREACHES ALL THIS,
"I'M HOLY. I'M THIS. I HAVE MY
BIBLE OPEN"?
AND HERE YOU ARE,
OPENIN' A CURTAIN,
AND YOU'RE TOPLESS,
AND YOU'RE SHAKING YOUR CHEST,
JIGGLE, SHIMMY.
I SAW THEM GO ROUND AND ROUND
AND UP AND DOWN.
Robin: NOW WHETHER OR NOT
THEY SHOOK OR WHATEVER,
I'M GOING TO OWN UP.
I'M GOING TO OWN UP
TO WHAT I DID.
Tyra: IT'S OKAY.
ROBIN, YOU ARE HUMAN.
Robin: RIGHT,
AND THEN TO BE HONEST WITH YOU,
IT'S NOT LIKE MR. JAY
HASN'T SEEN--
Janice: WHERE WAS YOUR BIBLE
WHEN YOU WERE SHAKING
YOUR TITTIES AT MR. JAY?
Robin: IT WAS RIGHT THERE
NEXT TO ME.
Tyra: LET'S JUST GO
TO THE NEXT THING.
I FEEL LIKE THIS IS NOT MAKING
ANY KIND OF SENSE.
Beau: CAN I MAKE A COMMENT?
I'M SORRY.
YOU KNOW, I APPRECIATE YOU
AND SHANNON TAKING YOUR STANDS.
I'M KIND OF DISAPPOINTED
THAT YOU DIDN'T DO IT.
I WAS SORT OF EXPECTING
THIS KIND OF, YOU KNOW,
BOTTICELLI IMAGE, YOU KNOW?
I WAS SAD THAT YOU JUST KIND OF
DIDN'T PUT YOURSELF OUT THERE,
YOU KNOW, REPRESENTING WOMEN
OF A DIFFERENT SIZE.
Tyra: I TOTALLY AGREE
WITH YOU, THAT IF YOU WOULD HAVE
DONE THAT PHOTO SHOOT AND SHOWED
THAT BIG BA-DONKA-DONK
CAN BE BEAUTIFUL
AND IT CAN BE SEXY,
AND "I CAN STAND RIGHT NEXT
TO THESE OTHER GIRLS
AND SERVE AND BE FIERCE,"
I THINK THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
A VERY STRONG PLATFORM.
Derek: THANK YOU, ROBIN.
Tyra: BYE.
♪♪♪
Tyra: ADRIANNE.
Beau: I THINK ADRIANNE LOOKS
PHENOMENAL IN THIS PICTURE.
Kimora: I DO THINK AT TIMES
SHE COMES ACROSS AS A BIT HARD.
I JUST WOULD LIKE TO SEE HER
TONE IT DOWN JUST A BIT.
Derek: SHE'S IMPROVED,
TO ME, TREMENDOUSLY
DURING THESE WEEKS
AS I'VE BEEN WORKING
REALLY CLOSELY WITH THEM,
AND I FIND, UM, SHE, TO ME,
IS JUST PHENOMENAL.
I JUST CAN'T FIND
ANYTHING WRONG WITH HER.
Tyra: ELYSE.
Janice: ELYSE'S PHOTOGRAPH
HERE IS THE MOST VERSATILE.
Tyra: I THINK
SHE'S PENETRATING THE LENS,
WHICH IS NOT THE MOST EASY THING
TO DO, ESPECIALLY FOR
AN AMATEUR MODEL.
SHANNON.
Kimora: THERE'S NO PICTURE.
Janice: I'M DEPRESSED
THAT SHANNON COULD NOT TAKE
THE ATTITUDE
OF THE OTHER TWO GIRLS.
BIG POINTS OFF IN MY BOOK
ON SHANNON.
Derek: I JUST FIND SHE'S JUST
REALLY STAGNATED AT
THAT ONE PART, THAT ONE LAUGH,
THAT ONE GRIN
OR THAT ONE SMILE.
WHAT KILLS IT IS
LIMITING HERSELF
TO THIS PHOTO SHOOT.
AS A TOP MODEL,
I'M NOT FEELING HER.
Tyra: OKAY. ROBIN.
Beau: IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
IMPORTANT FOR OTHER WOMEN
ROBIN'S SIZE TO SEE HER
BE KIND OF LANGUID AND SEXY
AND SHOWING OFF SOME SKIN.
Kimora: I DON'T THINK THAT
ROBIN IS ASHAMED OF HER BODY,
BECAUSE SHE'S SHOWN HER BODY
BEFORE IN THE SWIMWEAR
AND THE LINGERIE,
AND THE REPRESENTATION
THAT SHE SHOWS TO THE WORLD
IS A STRONG ONE THAT I THINK
IS VERY IMPORTANT.
Janice: IT'S CLEAR
THAT ROBIN DOESN'T HAVE
THE PERSONALITY
TO BE A TOP MODEL.
Beau: PHYSICALLY,
OF COURSE I COULD USE HER,
BUT THAT KIND OF BEHAVIOR
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT I WANNA
PROMOTE IN THIS INDUSTRY.
Tyra: I'M ON THE FENCE.
I RESPECT HER BEING, YOU KNOW,
SAYING THAT SHE'S NOT GONNA DO
THE NUDITY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
ABOUT HER.
I HONESTLY DON'T.
Janice: LET'S VOTE.
Tyra: HELLO, LADIES.
THERE ARE FOUR OF YOU
STANDING IN FRONT OF ME,
BUT ONLY THREE OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE IN YOUR QUEST
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Tyra: ELYSE.
ELYSE... BRAVO ON THIS PHOTO.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Tyra: ADRIANNE.
ADRIANNE, WE'VE ALL COME TO SEE
THAT YOU PHOTOGRAPH BEAUTIFULLY,
BUT WHEN YOU WALK IN THIS ROOM,
GIRL, YOU LOOK LIKE YOU ARE
READY TO LIFT 350 POUNDS.
Tyra: AND I'M NOT EVEN
TALKING ABOUT WHAT YOU
LOOK LIKE PHYSICALLY.
I'M TALKING ABOUT HOW YOU
WALK IN, AND YOU WALK IN LIKE,
(deep voice)
"YO, WHASSUP, TYRA?
YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW,
I HOPE YOU CHOOSE ME,
BUT IF YOU DON'T, IT'S COOL,
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYIN'?"
(normal voice) SO I WANT YOU
TO PRACTICE
JUST RELAXING YOUR SHOULDERS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
SHANNON AND ROBIN,
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
Tyra: ONLY ONE OF YOU
WILL STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ROBIN...
I ADMIRE YOUR FAITH,
I ADMIRE YOUR STRENGTH,
AND I ADMIRE THE FACT
THAT YOU SAID, "I AM ME,
AND I HAVE MY STANDARDS,
AND I WILL NOT SACRIFICE THAT."
BUT ONE THING THAT YOU HAVE
TO REMEMBER--
HUMAN IS BEAUTIFUL.
PERFECT IS BORING.
SHANNON...
YOU ARE AMAZINGLY BEAUTIFUL.
ONE THING ABOUT YOUR LOOK IS
AGAIN AND AGAIN WE HEAR
THAT IT IS TOO COMMERCIAL.
I GAVE YOU ADVICE
TO SLICK YOUR HAIR BACK.
I FELT LIKE, YOU KNOW,
YOU DIDN'T FOLLOW THAT ADVICE,
AND THAT ADVICE
WOULD HAVE JUST TAKEN YOU
TO THE NEXT LEVEL TODAY.
YOU SHOULD HAVE CAME IN HERE
TODAY WITH A CHIGNON SO TIGHT,
THAT HAIR SLICKED BACK
WHERE IT LOOKED LIKE
YOU HAD A FACE-LIFT.
♪♪♪
Tyra: SHANNON,
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARD BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
♪♪♪
Robin: IT'S MEANT A LOT
TO ME TO BE A PART OF THIS
BECAUSE, UM, I HAD THE CHANCE
TO SHOW, UM,
A VARIATION OF BEAUTY.
IT IS TIME FOR ME TO MOVE ON.
MY JOB HERE IS DONE.
♪♪♪
Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES FROM
OUR NEXT EPISODE.
Tyra: IT'S FASHION WEEK
IN NEW YORK
THE HEIGHT OF AMERICAN FASHION.
WITH ROBIN GONE, THE HOUSE RULE
IS ANYTHING GOES.
Adrienne: HOW DO YOU LIKE THESE
APPLES, BABY?
HOW DO YOU LIKE' EM?
HI, GUYS.
COME INTO THE HOUSE OF
BABY PHATS.
Tyra: AND IT'S TIME FOR OUR
THREE REMAINING FINALISTS
TO STRUT THEIR STUFF.
BABY PHATS DIDN'T THINK I DID A
GOOD JOB.
WHOO!
Tara: AND THE JUDGES FINALLY
CHOOSE
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
ALRIGHT JUDGES, LET'S DELIBERATE.